the first thesis and the primary thesis
which I document
in this book that I just mentioned
without the light of Christian with them
the first
point the the main center point of
document is
that the escaton
of The Vedic tradition and the escaton
of the Christian tradition booths are in
a way to establish a union with God
there's no question about that that's
what religion true religion is about but
the point is that The Vedic Union with
God and the Christian union with God are
totally different and in fact in a sense
the opposite
because
The Vedic Union with God I call it the
Nirvana option
because never Buddhism and Hinduism are
not
totally the same but the word Nirvana
which comes from the Buddha expresses it
so as perfectly as it can be expressed
Nirvana literally means blowing out like
a candle flame and this is really what
The Vedic path the the highest Vedic
Paths of vedantic path advisor pass
accomplishes and aims to accomplish it's
a blowing out
of the human now the point is uh it is a
very deeply philosophical
point to
discover that
there is something in us which
transcends the human
that means there is something called
Wolfgang Smith
but
if you wipe that out
if a super Yogi could put his hand on me
and
this Wolfgang Smith is gone
what would remain
is the new recalpa samadhi the Supreme
state of the vedantic way
the vedantic way is neuronic it is a way
of wiping out the nearly human
it's hard to describe these things
because this is we're touching Rock
Bottom here we're talking about
absolutely foundational things
so The Vedic path is nervonic in
uh in The Vedic tradition you speak
about nirvikalpa samadhi
it is a state which very few sadhus even
in India attain but every now and then
it is attained and for example
in the early in the first half of the
20th century there was a great
sadhu in India who had attained that new
vicarpa samadi state and I read about
him when I was very young
you have photographs of him there are
people who visited him and made
conversations and the point is that from
our point of view this was a human being
we could talk to him
and he could talk to us
but in reality
that human side was just a facade we
think of him that way he didn't
experience himself
as that in other words he had attained
the actual escaton of The Vedic religion
and their various names nivikarpa
samadhi uh
this is not Nirvana this is different
it's the same
exactly the same I'm convinced that
Buddha even though he was not
organically or historically related to
India another nevertheless he belongs in
The Vedic tradition
so that the distinction is accidental
it's not essential
so this is one escaton
and incidentally uh I mean it's like
Mount Everest it's it's too big for us
to
we can say the words but we don't really
have any conception about that you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy